hi it's Michele from lab math and beauty
science and my skin is annoyingly oily
if you have oily skin then you'll know
what a pain it is to deal with makeup
slides off your face
sunscreen slides around everything
slides around and you spend a lot of
your time trying not to look like a
Mirabal I've had so many people asking
me for my tips on how to deal with oily
skin so here it is oily skin is genetic
but sometimes if you're using the wrong
skin care products you can actually make
oily or even dry skin over produce oil
and this gives you basically oily skin
than you should have unfortunately some
of us like me are in the truly oily camp
or technically oily combo camp because
I've got oily t-zone and normal-ish
cheeks oily skin can also be dehydrated
which leads to this weird dry but oily
situation where your skin feels like a
tight piece of leather and it's a bit
dry and maybe cracked but it's also
covered in a thin or thick layer of oil
so a lot of people who think they have
dry skin but there's still a whole bunch
of oil you actually might have
dehydrated skin the first thing to do if
you're frustrated with having oily skin
is to make sure you're not having that
situation if you want a really detailed
guide on how to do a skin a validation
and a rundown of all the different skin
types and conditions I've made one in my
guide to basic skin care so let's say
your skin is actually oily what can you
do it's really tempting to wash your
skin with harsh cleansers to cut through
the oil and dry it out but don't do this
it is a trap
harsh cleansers will strip away both oil
and what's called your natural
moisturizing factor or nmf which is a
collection of chemicals that are in your
skin and these hold onto water and keep
it hydrated so it's like a natural
humectant moisturizer harsh surfactants
also warp the shape of some of the
proteins in your skin and this leads to
dehydration because it makes your skin
get leaky to water now your skin is
responsive to its own hydration
level when your skin's dehydrated it's
going to produce more oil to try to keep
your skin condition which means more oil
gentle cleansing is the way to go here
your skin isn't meant to feel tight and
dry after you wash it it should feel
soft and plump almost like it's been
very lightly moisturized if you're used
to really really dry clean skin after
washing then having properly washed skin
is going to feel a bit weird and it
might even feel like you haven't washed
properly for a bit but if you persevere
you'll eventually get used to it and
your skin will be so much better for it
gentle cleansing was the number one
thing that helped my oily skin there are
a lot of things that can go into finding
a gentle cleanser but the easiest thing
to do is to avoid sodium lauryl sulfate
in the top ingredients of your cleanser
and to also avoid soaps the reason is
the molecules of these ingredients are
really skinny
so they insert themselves into your skin
quite easily sort of like a pin sliding
into your skin and that means that they
stay in your skin and keep irritating it
even after you've washed it off these
ingredients are also more stripping
which means they're more likely to take
away the oils and the nmf in your skin
even gentle cleansers can cause some of
these effects which is why I recommend
that you try to clean your skin as
little as possible so for me I only
cleanse my skin properly at night once a
day with cleanser in the morning I just
use water I splash my face with the
water and rub it around a bit and then
Pat a dry with a towel using less
cleanser has helped my oily skin a lot I
found that the oil tends to come back a
bit slower throughout the day instead of
sort of like just flooding my entire
face and if feels a lot more comfortable
so there isn't that weird type feeling
and that whole greasy dehydrated flaky
shiny gross leathery situation has cut
back a lot I've listed a couple of
gentle cleansers that I really like in
the caption but remember that everyone's
skin is different so it's really
important for you to work out what your
skin likes and how your skin responds to
different situations
[Music]
it's really tempting to think that if
your skin is oily then it doesn't need
any more moisturizer because it's giving
itself way too much already but again
this is another trap your natural Sieben
isn't actually that good at moisturizing
if your skin is hydrated and oily then
maybe you don't need another moisturizer
but if your skin's dehydrated and oily
which is the case for a lot of people
then having a hydrating moisturizer that
addresses your dehydration issues with
lots of occlusives and humectants this
will help you control your oiliness
[Music]
salicylic acid which is commonly known
as beta hydroxy acid is a chemical
exfoliant and an anti inflammatory acne
treating skincare ingredient it's
recommended for oily skin a lot because
it's oil soluble which means it's more
likely to be able to get through into
your blackheads and into your acne and
clear them out as far as I know there
haven't been actual studies on whether
or not this is true but it sounds pretty
reasonable oily skin tends to have
bigger pores and I've personally found
that my pores look a lot less noticeable
if I've been consistently using
salicylic acid for a while the product I
use most of the time is Paula's Choice
true percent VHA liquid but there are a
lot of options out there and if you want
to find out more about exfoliation I've
made a free guide that you can download
in the link below unfortunately there
aren't that many skincare ingredients
that have been found to reduce the
amount of oil in your face and for the
months that there are there's usually
like one single study on each of them so
it's probably not very reliable and they
might not actually work there's one
study where they used a true percent
niacinamide serum and this reduced the
amount of oil that was on people's faces
there's another study that found that a
plant extract of saw palmetto in a cream
also reduced oiliness
there's also vitamin A derivatives like
retinol and threatenin and these can
theoretically reshape the ducts that
your oil comes out of and this slows
down how much it pulls out of your skin
you can also use the claim
asked to soak up any oil that's sitting
in your pores on your skin but you do
have to use these quite regularly so
that you keep the oil at bay I find that
using it twice or three times a week is
necessary I use a lot of translucent
powder for soaking up the oil on my skin
I use it pretty much every day if I
don't use it then there's no hope for me
the ingredient that I found the best for
this is starch so things like corn
starch rice - arrowroot powder there's
tons and tons of starches I always look
for starch high up somewhere in the
ingredients list some translucent
powders also have clay which is also
pretty good at soaking up oil one trick
that you can use for soaking up oil is
Wayne Gauss's method which is where you
put a really light layer of powder under
your foundation so that you can soak up
the oil before it hits the surface so
before anyone can see it and so that
means that your foundation isn't going
to slide around as much because you've
just got this extra oil soaking powder
in there Multi sunscreening is my wife
for using different sunscreens on
different parts of my face so for me
I've got lots of hyperpigmentation here
on the tops of my cheeks and they get
much much worse with like a tiny tiny
bit of Sun so I want to really protect a
sunscreen on this area but the problem
is sunscreens with really high
protection tend to also be really greasy
and thick and uncomfortable so I don't
want to use the high protection
sunscreen everywhere because these bits
are gonna get super super greasy so what
I do is I put the normal sunscreen
everywhere and then I go back and I put
the high protection sunscreen on the
bits that need it if you decide to do
this you need to make sure that you Pat
your second sunscreen on really gently
to try to avoid shifting the lower layer
around too much you also need to make
sure that the sunscreen ingredients are
actually compatible and they weren't
interact with each other and just cancel
each other out so for example I usually
use true ultra suitable sunscreens that
have the same active ingredients
[Music]
blotting papers are really really good
for getting rid of oil in the middle of
the day without messing up your makeup
too much just grab one of these and you
Pat it on gently on the oily bits to
soak it up my favourites are the thin
paper ones I don't really like using the
plastic ones because it just feels like
I'm beating up Mother Nature when I use
them you can also use toilet paper and
napkins as well it's been so ingrained
in my head over the years that matters
the way to go with makeup for oily skin
but recently ish I found that using dewy
makeup Ashley works better for me the
reason is when I do get oily then the
contrast between the oily bits and the
non oily parts is a bit less obvious
than if I have the matte foundation and
if I have the matte foundation and I
have the oil then it looks really really
patchy so I either look either kind of
glowy / slightly sweaty or just gross
and decomposing I usually mix an
illuminating sort of fluid into my
foundation and then I add highlighter on
the tops of my cheeks and on the end of
my nose and a little bit on my phone as
well then I put the starch powder on top
and that seems to work pretty well there
are a lot of anti oil makeup products
and pore filling primers that have lots
of silicones in them but I've actually
personally found that too many silicones
make me look even worse they look really
nice for about half an hour or so and
then the oil soaks into them and then
suddenly it all starts moving around on
my face and I look like I'm made of
melting wax
[Music]
there are also some medical treatments
that can reduce oil production to many
androgens which are male sex hormones
can make you produce way too much oil
and there are some medications that can
reduce this so for example combined oral
contraceptive pills and spironolactone
isotretinoin which is also known as
accutane can also cut down on the oil
most of the time these prescription
medications aren't really used just for
treating oily skin but they are used for
acne and reducing oil is one of the side
effects if you're interested in these go
to your doctor and chat to them about
whether or not it's right for your
particular situation
there are also some newer treatments and
ingredients that are promising for
treating oily skin so for example Botox
and laser and light treatments but
they're still pretty expensive at the
moment and the evidence behind them so
far isn't all that convincing so those
are some of my tips for coping with oily
skin do you already use these do you
have a chip I didn't cover let me know
in the comments if you liked my video
you can also subscribe to my channel if
you want more regular beauty tips you
can follow me on Facebook and Instagram
I also have a blog where I have tons and
tons of articles on beauty products and
the signs behind them see you next time
for more beauty science
[Music]
[Music]